again
like it's this the same talk we
had
is you can't learn
it by being told what to do you
can't you have to learn
it through the fear that has you not
learning it do you understand
so the I the
dream
that you're going to modify
yourself without the
repercussions for not modifying
yourself is delusion it's not going to
happen you understand so you have to be
thrown for
real and then learn the hard way when
you resist the real throw it's the only
way you're going to change no one
changes the other way your brother
didn't learn it the way
you want to learn it do you understand
and he can do it okay he he got hit he
cried got it he don't cry
anymore
right you just suck it up until you
don't need to suck it up anymore because
it's normal and natural for you that's
how you learn
use that qu to free that qua okay so
that qua freeze it freeze
it freeze it
[Music]
you you have to move it you have to
move try
so careful you're not doing tensin net
cuz tenin net is going to be here on the
neck tenin net lets his Center come
through you
see this one pay attention to the heaven
arm okay the heaven arm's turning him
you
see so the the tensi heaven arm goes
this
way c n heav and arm goes this
way you guys see that right
so tension Naga
here and then close you net going
here it turns him
okay so T
net and
CI P
you okay let's go to stand e
okay so on on
ten the bottom hand does the same thing
at the beginning with Co net the bottom
hand the Earth hand does the same thing
I have to bring It Center forward okay
but once you when you on tension n when
you bring his Center forward is to here
to that adhesion
point I'll have that adhesion Point okay
so here on his face inside his
palm so and and I brought him in without
turning him so right now his progress is
going that
way that means that foot has to go there
can't be in the back back back switch
feet so that he could
turn you guys see that you're you're
you're doing this to him you're doing
this like a you're doing
this you can't go
backwards okay so you can't you can't
leave it back there to turn okay so
you're bringing him to here and then
that's hitting hitting and
adhering so you have
energy that's pulling him forward and
this thing here okay try to turn towards
me you see that you feel that resistance
okay and then to that I add this you see
and he can't turn
so I don't want him to
turn can't turn Okay I I
want this back R
fall does he come up yes but does he
turn no does he turn himself no okay on
this one I'm going to turn him with this
maneuver
yes because the hands the same does he
come forward is is Chris's pressure here
you see yes
okay but now I take the B leg and move
it around you see I don't move
his I don't let his front
leg turn all right like that nor do I
let him do that okay I don't make I
don't let him do that he can't do it so
he comes forward there's the front leg
then I turn
him you're
turning you can talk this on the way
down
and
she P
you okay try it
all right so again we're trying to see
the difference between the koku hand and
the and the tenin hand so my Earth
hand yes he's spal displacing so yes
there's a Yin yield but I'm also I want
you to
feel that in here there's like a four
that's bringing you in got it is a force
here so on the I'm not just getting out
of the way it's moving you do you see
there's
teni it's on the inside and it's a
bigger spiral but do do you feel that
Force
there
okay and C you Nota one
is going to turn and get his elbow St
and you're going to get his elbow the
counter force is here going this
way so this one's in your hand here it
just brings you in and this one gets
your elbow and brings that elbow
in so that's where you need to feel it
you you can't just get out of the way
get out of the way okay you're inside
here on the grip right here that's where
you move him
forward and on the other one it's on his
elbow that moves him forward
okay likewise on on these Heaven
hands when you are
here they don't do the C you on the same
part of his body okay so I was using
that to bring him
forward and it's not going to work going
the other way okay and that's why you
changed your adhesion point so your
adhesion point is no not in his group
anymore it's on his
head so
ten is going to use this kind of energy
and then this energy
making a circle in between so they're
they're not conflicting okay so you you
can feel it then I'm here there's the
circle on your face right such that for
example they can let go he's not holding
and I'll still get that you see and he
can take his arm off
completely the technique still has his
contact points okay
on the
Kos it's in his elbow that I want okay
so I go to his elbow to bring him
forward not not his grip his
elbow is bringing him forward like
that from this adhesion
Point okay now once you get here this
does not go up to the head because he's
turning under it there's really no
pressure
there it throws in the hand so you bring
his elbow up and it throws here in the
hand this
way so that don't come out of this and
go to
here you come in and then you use the
hand you you stick there on the hand you
stick on the hand to do the throw
inh if you do too positive a
y you're here you're like you're going
to come over I went over his head and
the technique he floats you you adhere
in the hand okay the Earth hand does
change but not doesn't change at this
point so
ten it's the same
same I'm using that adhesion point right
and this one here kou nag same as far as
that hand goes in his
elbow but after that they change so
tension Naga goes here and down
under to assist this contact
Point kofu nag goes here and then over
the top so that this doesn't keep
traveling that way and this projection
on his
arm gets him to go Topsy
turby so tenaga stays
under cou net over the top
okay um so CH you can't just do one
inward spiral for every technique okay
try it again very key to this technique
as we already said right right Chris is
that his Center is going forward has to
be going forward because this has to
become his front foot on both
techniques okay and he can't pick it up
and turn his body this way right like
you see everywhere okay and the way he
can't turn his body he can't pick the
foot up is it was your pressure coming
here
okay
so you you will have those Su that they
don't want to come in well then then
they get all their agency back okay so
you're over here like that you see how
say there please he he pinned his feet
and he can't come in okay so make sure
you don't pin him and you keep using you
can let go this hand NOP just want you
to feel this okay and this is what keeps
moving you
see you can see how far he he's coming
in you're just you're just like not
you're just doing the outside instead of
no no no I I'm going to use all of this
you can see how right now he he can't
come in if I start going back pen so I
just keep bringing them
in okay and you're going to be better
off
Margaret same thing here right I'm
trying to do this one like she's already
wanting to turn do you see that no no no
no no no no no no no no I'm working that
elbow you see I work the elbow
work the
elbow just keep bringing the
elbow she wants to turn already but
we're not done just keep bringing there
we go then you can do the
ticking want to turn already you see
that foot no no no here and just keep
working the elbow working it every every
time she lengthens the arm do you do you
see that go back go back go back go back
okay watch when you feel the pull look
at your elbow straight
okay see see that that's her little
counters just take her into it there's a
little counter again just keep taking
her into it
okay and then here's your forward roll
right
there okay you you're going to be better
off training that way
and understanding where the opening for
the technique is and where it's not then
letting your
UK do whatever they want to do okay
right cuz we're we're not going to Chuck
you and let's say I could and am I now
Marshall I I defeated the universe
metric for martial
Margaret no I'm working instead on the
um Mechanics for the throw the
energetics for the throw do you get it
so I know she can't be where she wants
to be oh I'm going to keep bringing her
where the technique needs to be and I
would put before you that you're much
closer to a marsh likeo if you do that
then you try to hit her in the face or
throw her right there and then because
you can feel when she's trying to get in
and out of the technique and you're
bringing her back into the technique and
you're now doing spontaneous energetic
work at that point in kihon waza okay
all right so let's now the qua is
involved in the two techniques okay so
on this qua look where it opens it opens
here opens
here
okay on the other one has not open do
you see see hasn't open gets him going
and here's where it opens that's where
your turn
come that way youran AR going way over
here the qua turns him okay so I going
one has hasn't opened it's actually
closed right now okay brings comes up
into his
elbow and now is where it releases boom
stay in the
half Kook Naga I'm sorry teni Naga opens
at the start to get rid of to reconcile
this final displacement okay so boom it
opens goes the other
side turns here
boom C
you boom look where it
turns back here other one is going to
open
here right at the
start and
G it's closed it's
open
here open at the start so I can get out
of this contention here and get to the
other side of it you
see turns
stay in the
hand reconcile go to the
head stay in the
half so pay
attention to when this what this does
from here cuz I want to stay in the hand
if I start turning it down too early I'm
going to come out of the hand so it
stays Palm up you see
till he's off of
[Music]
it Palm up
boom when he's off of it is now in his
Yin phase this when it comes
down T
[Music]
boom
co
T you
notice how it doesn't come down okay try
it